[Applause]
necklace platoon in the middle it goes
off
for george works on davis
george with a three that's good and paul
george the other way
driving right back kuzma takes it up and
puts it in
i mean look how effortless this is just
goes right by kuzma
when they sign kuzma to that contract
extension gone nine of 18 combined from
the floor they've got 26 points combined
off the bench this is how they envision
hero to play
for the final stretch of the third
quarter
george three leonard is resting with
22 points on the bench paul george is
getting hot
sign that big contract right before the
season
paul george is hot boy he has had a
string of shots here that have gone in
now with 24.
gennard and george and zubots puts on
the brakes puts up a three and now dude
george has
27. lebron with 22 points that's a three
good 30 on 17 shots and here's the
contact by
caldwell pope down low sending
pg-13 to the line for a four-point play
opportunity
what a tremendous shooting display in
the second half
we're starters out there and lou
williams
threw off the bench has tonight put in
nine
george got it again paul george hits
another one